انطلاقا من هذه التصريحات القادمه من
الغرفه المشتركه لفصائل المقاومه ماذا
يمكن ان نقول بشان ربما هذه الجهوزيه
والامكانيات المتوفره حاليا لدى الفصائل
وهل هناك ما قد يفاجئ الجانب الاسرائيلي
في هذه الجوله الجديده
الفصائل الفلسطينيه نتحدث عن امور لا يمكن
الافصاح عنها مسبقا ولكن ما كانت تتحدث
عنه الفصائل الفلسطينيه خلال جولات
التصعيد السابقه وخلال التهديدات
المتواصله من قبل الحكومات الاسرائيليه
خاصه الحكومه اليمينيه المتطرفه الحاليه
التي كانت تنذر وتهدد بشكل مستمر بامكانيه
البدء بعمليات موسعه على قطاع غزه فكانت
دائما الفصائل الفلسطينيه ترد بان
المقومين وفصائل المقاومه على جهوزيه تامه
لمواجهه اي عدوان اسرائيلي او اي
عمليات اسرائيليه قد تقدم عليها على قطاع
غزه عندما كانت تتحدث الفصائل الفلسطينيه
المقاومه الفلسطينيه في السابق عن
استعدادات وعن تطوير
قدراتها فانها كانت تقول بان المفاجات
ستكون على الارض هي لا تعلن عن هذه
الاستعدادات لتعلن عن هذا التطور لا تعلن
عن ما تملكه من اسلحه جديده ولكن ما
شهدناه والدليل قاطع على هذه التصريحات ما
شهدناه في عام 2021 عندما بدات
الفصائل الفلسطينيه بالرد على الاعتداءات
والجرائم التي تقوم بها سلطات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في مدينه القدس والاعتداء على
حرمه القدس والمقدسات الاسلاميه والمسيحيه
في مدينه القدس كان الرد بطريقه
واستراتيجيه جديده نحن نتحدث عن تطوير
لهذه القدرات العسكريه التي تملكها
المقاومه ولكن ايضا ما شاهدناه هذه الايام
هو ايضا تكتيكات واستراتيجيات جديده ليس
فقط قدرات هو توظيف هذه القدرات بطريقه
جديده وبدراسات جديده وبسياسات جديده قد
تكون تفضي الى منحنيات جديده في المواجهه
وعندما يتم الحديث عن مواجهات كبرى وعن
توسيع نطاق
المقاومه لعملياتها ولاطلاق الصواريخ لا
يخفى على
المتابعين كيف ان المقاومه باستراتيجيتها
وبامتلاكها لمقومات متطوره وتطوير ما
لديها من امكانيات استطاعت ان تشل الحركه
في اسرائيل لمده 10 ايام فيما يعام عام
فعلا توجيه هذه الصواريخ بطريقه دقيقه
عندما كان الحديث عن صواريخ ستوجه الى
مطار محدد وستوجه الى منطقه محدده وحتى
كانت تحدد الساعات في بعض الاحيان كانت
بالفعل تنفذ وبالفعل كانت تتمكن من شل الح
ركه احيانا حركه مروريه واحيانا حركات
تجاريه واحيانا الطيران والتحركات
الاستراتيجيه في اسرائيل مما يعني ان ما
تقوله المقاومه دليل على ان هذه
الامكانيات في تطور مستمر وما تعلن عنه
المقاومه ليس مجرد للدعايه او للاعلان
ولكن بالفعل هي تمتلك ما تثبته على الارض
كما تتحدث الفصائل المختلفه للمقاوم
الفلسطينيه